hello everyone i want to invite you to
an event which will be happening from
september 16th to the 18th in thunder
bay ontario called consciousness and
conscience it is going to be a
conference where i will be there with
john vervecki with paul vander clay and
also with dr richard mandrell for those
who follow the uh this little corner of
the internet you will see that this is
the closest thing to a conference
bringing us all together that we're
gonna have in a little while it is the
closest thing to a symbolic world
conference as well
it's going to be several days of talks
of discussions and it's even going to
start a few days early on the 14th where
we're going to have an airsoft and
barbecue and it really shows you what is
the the purpose of this conference is to
to get together to discuss ideas to also
get to know each other so i'm really
excited to participate in this my own
talk will be called
love and attention
and i'll be looking at the manner in
which love binds together our attention
and why i think that this is really the
glue of consciousness in general and
kind of one of the secrets to how
reality presents itself to you
and so but mostly really i'm looking
forward to
being there with you guys with paul
vander clay who i've never met with john
viveki who i always love to be together
and discovering also dr richard monroe
who i don't know yet i think it's going
to be a wonderful event and i'm really
hoping to see you there if you want to
sign up go to urbanabby.ca
conference and look up consciousness and
conscience um i'm going to drive there
you know because of our situation in
canada i'm actually going to drive like
15 hours in order to get to the
conference so once i'm there i'm going
to be excited to uh to make the most of
the time i have with all you guys there
so i hope to see you there and to meet
you there and uh thanks